so let me zoom in on a very particular
aspect of street fighting
where uh with all due respect i disagree
with mr joe rogan
and george st pieron which is uh the
suit and tie situation
now to criticize gsp yeah yeah he's very
accomplished and everything but
to criticize him for a bit he made
claims about
how dangerous the tie is in a street
fighting
situation without ever having used them
in a fighting situation
so he made sort of br broad
proclamations without
understanding the fundamentals so i
thought i would go to somebody who uh
thinks in systems what do you think
is it um is it dangerous to wear a tie
or not
in a grappling situation versus all the
other weapons
in a street fight here was that strange
to wear a tie in a grappling competition
he would be it would be uh yes in a in a
street fight situation okay yeah joe
rogan thinks
it is like the most dangerous
it's like it becomes your weakest point
if you wear a tie because it's very easy
to choke
george saint pierre seemed to have
agreed with that also george added
that you can grab the tie and pull the
person down
uh to a knee yeah this is this is the
go-to joe rogan will go for the choke
george st pierre will go for the tie to
the knee which i was saying is
ridiculous so what do you think
okay um first up i actually can speak
with experience on this because i worked
as a bouncer for
over a decade and most of the clubs i
worked at did not require a suit and
time but occasionally they did
okay let's first differentiate between
the kinds of threats when you wear a tie
yes if you wear a tie if there is going
to be a threat by far the more important
threat
is not strangulation okay being
strangled by your tie
is possible but it is a poor choice
there are many other ways to strangle
people that are far more efficient if i
strangle with you
you're by your tie i'm literally in
front of you
um that means as i go to apply the
stranglehold i can easily be eye gouged
sarah sarah if you're going to strangle
people on the street do it from behind
and
there's just much better ways to do it
than that hear that joe rogan
with regards to the snap down question
that's that
is more of a problem i always recommend
if you are going to work as a bouncer
with a tie
wear a clip-on tie so it just comes off
immediately
if you don't like clip-ons then you can
use a bow tie i used to work
for years with uh in hip-hop clubs
with uh members of the nation of islam
security team
they were known they had various
factions but the one i worked with
with the x-men and they would always
wear bow ties which of course can't be
grabbed
now um
the bow tie was it was a recognizable
part of their brand a security guard so
everyone knew that
that's what they were if if i wore a bow
tie and a security situation people
would probably think that i was some
kind of nancy boy
and um and want to fight with me so i
couldn't wear one
so i would always wear a tie which you
should become familiar with mr freeman
that's the texas
bolo tie which is a kind of shoestring
tie
which is very very thin almost like
shoestring and rather short
and just has a simple pendant in the
middle
this is perfect if you need to wear a
tie in a situation where you believe
there's a
high likelihood of you being grabbed
because i can't be grabbed yeah there's
nothing to grab it's literally like
string like if
if you pulled it it would just slip
through your hand um that tie that
you're wearing now
that would give me tremendous control of
your head and
i could easily turn into a hockey fight
situation where your head was being
pulled down out of balance
and you would have a hard time
recovering
so strangulation not really a problem
getting pulled down possible problem
solutions clip-on tie bow tie
or if you don't want to look like an
etsy boy wear a um
a bolo tie beautiful so you disagree
with joe rogan agree with george st
pierre i love it
i feel like with i feel like this is an
instruction we put together
on uh on street fighting and the tie
you